Так сталося історично,
що церква завжди впливає на свідомість громадян.
Нам не можна втрачати українську мову,
не можна її забувати,
і так само нам не можна українську церкву.
Кожна людина робить якісь зміни в суспільстві.
Насправді це кайф робити те, що тобі подобалося з дитинства.
Уявіть, небагато людей займається
тим, чим їм хочеться.
— Мене, до речі, Марино хитало знову.
— Мене теж...
— Я думала, що тільки мене [хитало]
— Я прийшла, сіла і ось так...
Я постійно відчувала це хитання.
Ілля, не цей...
Жодна наливайка на працює ввечері,
вся молодь на спорт майданчиках.
Кажу: «Це вселяє надію.»
Я живу в Маріуполі все своє життя.
Таке індустріальне місто,
жителям якого неправильно нав'язували довгі роки,
що заводи — то наше все.
Світає, Господи, світає…
Земля у росах, як в парчі.
Маріє, Діво Пресвятая,
це ти так плакала вночі?
Якісь он квіти, сині-сині,
на голу цеглу повились.
Спиває ранок по росині,
як в нас під хатою колись.
Ілля!
Храм цей з'явився десь 22 роки точно.
Придбала цю будівлю, яку була в морському
пароходстві і почали реконструкцію.
Не було там десь підлоги, десь стелі не було...
Десь стіни були такі...
Я, пам'ятаю, коли була маленька,
то часто сюди піднімалася.
[російською] Її теж можна так обійняти!
[російською] Всіх пообнімали!
— Добрий ранок!
— Добрий день!
Три роки тому в мене виникла ідея розписати
храм українським орнаментом петриківським.
Але на той час ще храм був неготовий,
стіни були непідготовлені.
Можливо, цей проєкт мав «вистоятися» ці 3 роки.
От, і якось так все притихло.
Храм був ще недобудований,
ще ззовні були роботи — і так і літо пройшло,
не довели до кінця.
І вже в цьому році
вирішили таки розписати.
[російською] Все, котику, я полізла. Давай, па-па!
Ми познайомилися з місцевим
маріупольським волонтером — Кирилом Далінбаєвим.
Одного разу він приїхав і ми йому
провели екскурсію на другий поверх.
Каже: «А чому ви не розписуєте його ззовні?
Був же такий проєкт».
Він запропонував нам  спробувати
зробити волонтерський проєкт,
написав пост у Фейсбуці і тоді люди
потихеньку почали фінансувати.
Долучилося загалом 350 людей,
вдалося зібрати 10 тисяч доларів
за 2 з половиною місяці.
Я приїхала сюди 15 червня,
приїхала подивилася.
І вже 16 червня ми приступили до розпису.
Так, Оля зібралася і приїхала!
Кирило їй подзвонив і запропонував
взяти участь у такому проєкті.
Вона сказала, що зможе,
і вже 15 червня була тут.
Це найбільший петриківсий розпис, наймасштабніший.
Є прикрашені храми,
але в таких масштабах — це перший.
Покликали щось запропонувати,
ну а що я можу запропонувати,
коли я художник петриківського розпису?
Ну звісно, я запропонувала петриківський розпис!
Він позитивний.
Навіть якщо ти сідаєш [писати]
і на щось розлючений,
роздратований, все одно заспокоюєшся
і починаєш виводити.
Мабуть, плавність тих ліній, переходів,
поєднання кольорів налаштовує,
заспокоює і дарує гарний настрій.
Біля воріт юрмилися цікаві.
Чого вже там ті люди не верзуть?
Вже кат пройшов, аж грухнуло в Полтаві:
– Везуть Марусю, людоньки, везуть!
Везуть Марусю за далекі гони,
за сиве море тої ковили.
Уже голів судейських макогони
в степу на вітрі мідно загули.
Вже п’яний Дзизь ведмежу губу кривить,
все поводи натягує: – Гаття!
А там в степу… а там в степу, як привид,
стоять оті ворота в небуття.
Під час роботи в роцесі розпису
мені найбільше подобається спілкування,
майже ніколи не працюємо мовчки,
ділимося якимись життєйскими історіями.
Намагаємося знайти вихід із ситуацій.
Дуже важливо, коли є з ким
поспілкуватися, слухаємо музику,
читаємо, ділимося якимись секретами...
Ну, дві дівчини працюють,
хіба нам немає про що порозмовляти?
Найскладніше для мене була висота.
Розпис фасаду, це вже
не вперше в моїй практиці,
нічого складного для мене немає,
бо я вже знаю як з тим працювати.
А от саме висота, це одне з найскладніших.
Я піднялася сюди на другий поверх
і якраз познайомилася з Олею,
вона спустилася з дзвіниці.
Вона була трохи налякана висотою,
але тепер це позаду.
Я коли приїхала і дивилася
на все це знизу,
я не хотіла думати про те,
що треба буде лізти туди.
Виявляється, можна звикнути до висоти.
Я коли починала працювати тут,
то спочатку починали з першого поверхау
потім — другий, потім — третій, потім далі,
і так піднімаєшся кожен день
на поверх вище на лісах,
і в принципі, звикаєш.
Все можна приборкати, навіть страх.
І все. І досить. Засинаєш.
Така непам’ять огорта…
А що, тепер, Марусю, знаєш,
що значить в світі самота?
Ніхто до тебе не озветься,
хоч би й покликала кого.
Лише об стіни обіб’ється
луна од голосу твого.
Оля мені сказала, що це літо в неї буде
асоціюватися з Марусею Чурай,
бо, коли ми на дзвіниці працювали
і так як вишка нас обмежує в русі
так могло бути, що я завершила
свій орнамент, а Оля ще робить.
І тому я просто сиділа, і тоді Оля сказала мені:
«Ти щось мені розкажи або почитай».
– Пропустіть матір, хай стане ближче.
Хто-хто, а вона заслужила.
– Перехрестіться, яку матір?!
– Та Грицькову.
– А-а-а, Грицькову.
– Марусину ж не випустили з міста.
Вона ж така вже там, напівжива.
В принципі я люблю творчість Ліни Костенко...
Я її спитала, чи вона читала «Марусю Чурай»,
вона сказала, що ні.
Якось так склалося, що ні і
вона почала мені читати.
Ну, нам, можна сказати.
Їй подобається і мені подобається, класно!
Аж навіть кат не витримав, зачовгав,
заніс мішок, узявшись за краї, –
чи щоб вона не бачила нічого,
чи так нестерпно бачити її!
Це в нас центральний вхід,
тут буде бібліотека та церковна лавка.
Можемо подивитись...
Тут планується клас недільної школи.
Це ж ми не просто церкву розписуємо,
ми хотіли б,
щоб ця церква була місцем не тільки,
куди люди можуть прийти помолитися
або взяти участь у церковних таїнствах,
а також місцем, де вони і культурно
можуть чимось збагатитись.
Плануємо робити і Оліну виставку в кінці проєкту,
і місцевих художників, залучати людей до цього.
Тобто така освітньо-просвітницька діяльність.
[розмовляють між собою]
Стереотипи, звісно, є, що це — шароварщина.
Ще це як брелоки...
Ну така дрібна сувенірка.
Але петриківський розпис
мені здається набагато ціннішим,
бо він дуже різним може бути,
його можна органічно використовувати
в інтер'єрі, в екстерьєрі,
ну от в данному випадку, бачите?
Ми розписуємо храм: це ж не брелок,
це не дощечка на кухню чи щось таке дрібне.
Моя ціль, місія — це вивести петриківку
з цього русла — шароварщини.
Їй говорили, а вона не чула.
І тільки коли матір підвели,
вона відразу наче спам’яталась,
і одхитнулась від того стовпа,
і якось наче здалеку верталась,
чогось вперед руками, як сліпа.
Іще бліда, іще мов крейда біла,
а наче й усміхалась, лебеділа:
– От бачте, мамо, все і обійшлося. –
І цілувала матері волосся.
Дуже важливо мати тут, на Сході,
українську церкву.
Можна сказати, що православна церква України
є певним осередком українськості.
Зараз про українську церкву
дізнається набагато більше людей.
Це приверне увагу увагу і до української культури,
і до української церкви,
і до Маріуполя, і взагалі — до України.
Це така велика робота, що мені здається,
що всю значимість її я буду ще потім розуміти з часом.
— А взагалі який там кінець?
— Я не скажу!
Я не скажу! [сміється]
— Так а ти мені так і не дочитала?
— Ні, не дочитала.
— У мене так і не буде часу почитати.
— Буде-буде час.
І от я переосмислила Маріуполь і полюбила,
для мене більше України тут,
бачу свою роль тут,
в тому, щоб розвивати її тут.
Ми можемо багато змінити самі.
Людям вже не так байдуже, як це було до війни.
Багато жителів вже просто страждають від екології.
Ми мріємо про те, що заводи закриються
і в нас буду класне туристичне місто з морем
і різними об'єктами культурними і просвітницькими.